l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale de Monsieur Alain Foucher monsieur
le ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur le
ministre je souhaite attirer votre
attention sur le fond exceptionnel de
soutien au département dit en difficulté
le président de la République s'est
engagé en 2012 à mettre en place un fond
pour accompagner le financement des
départements ne pouvant faire face en
premire lieu à leurs dépenses sociales
en effet tous sont confrontés à la
diminution de leur recette fiscal et à
une forte augmentation de ce type de
dépense à caractère social Revenu de
Solidarité Active allocation
personnalisé à l'autonomie petite
enfance et cetera nous sommes très
nombreux ici à vouloir connaître les
véritables modalités de répartition de
ce fond à la lecture du tableau de
ventilation le constat saute aux yeux 80
% du fond auraiit été octroyés à des
départements socialistes ou divers
gauches force et de constater que la
corise département du président sauf
erreur de ma part a été le plus aid
l'exécutif a voté un budget en déficit
ce qui est d'ailleurs illégal avec une
capacité d'autofinancement en chute si
le fond avait servi à compenser des
dépenses à caractère social chacun
aurait pu comprendre or ce type de
dépense représente moins de 46 % du
budget à notre connaissance il s'agit
donc de dépenses d'investissement de
nombreux départements à l'image du mien
la Vienne où l'action sociale représente
plus de 50 % du budget ne bénéficie
d'aucune part de ce fond c'est à
l'évidence une répartition je pense
politique et arbitraire l'idée était
généreuse et très attendu par les élus
locaux mais la déception est grande
monsieur le ministre trois départements
mais c'est vrais les chiffres sont vrais
ont bénéficié de 30 % de l'enveloppe
globale la corise obtenu plus de 13
millions d'euros suivent le Tarne la
Guyane et cetera je n'y suis pas opposé
naturellement mais le soutien de l'État
doit être égalitaire à situation
identique l'incompréhension domine et
chacun peut le comprendre j'en profite
pour vous renouveler l'inquiétude des
élus locaux quant à la dégradation
importante des finances locales et
notamment récemment celle engendrée par
les rythmes scolaires sans compensation
financière parce qu'il n'y a pas de
compensation financière donc il faudrait
que le maire et de de le mettre en place
il faudrait que l'on puisse reporter
pour les communes qui ne sont pas prêtes
et que les financement de ce transfert
des charges aux collectivités soit
assumé par l'État comme cela doit se
faire normalement je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre de votre éclairage
qui sera très important merci la parole
est donc à Monsieur Thierry Repentin
ministre chargé des affaires européen
oui monsieur le sénateur Foucher ma
réponse sera effectivement très
détaillée pour qu'il n'y ait plus
ambiguité à l'issue de de celle-ci
s'agissant d'ailleurs d'une réponse qui
ne vient pas spécifiquement de Manuel
Vals mais de mes collègues Marie-Lise
Lebranchu et Anne-Marie Escoffier est
considéré que le ministre ici répond
pour les trois ministres absent pour
vous rappeler effectivement que le
Président de la République avait pris un
engagement il était tenu puisque la loi
de finances rectificative du 29 décembre
2012 a créé un fond exceptionnel de
soutien au département en difficulté
doté de 170 millions d'euros composé de
deux sections la première d'un montant
de 85 millions a été réparti ainsi que
le prévoit la loi au profit de la moitié
des départements les plus mal classés au
regard d'un indice synthétique prenant
en compte la proportion de bénéficiaires
de l'Allocation personnalisée pour
l'autonomie du revenu de solidarité
active de la prestation de compensation
du handicap pondéré par la population du
département la loi précise que
s'agissant de la seconde section du fond
de soutien doté également de 85 millions
d'euros je cite des subventions
exceptionnelles peuvent être versées en
section de fonctionnement à des
départements connaissant une situation
financière dégradée du fait en
particulier du poids des dépenses
sociales chaque département pouvait
déposer un dossier de candidature afin
de bénéficier d'une attribution au titre
de cette section 57 départements se sont
portés candidats pour bénéficier d'une
attribution au titre de cette seconde
section l'inspection générale de
l'administration a été missionné par le
ministère de la réforme de l'État de la
décentralisation de la fonction publique
et par la ministre délégée chargée de la
décentralisation pour étudier
l'éligibilité des départements à cette
seconde section du fond exceptionnel de
soutien l'IGA a rendu un rapport
analysant ses candidatures et proposant
une liste de départements éligible il
sa'est monsieur le sénateur fondé sur
six critères objectifs relatif pour
trois d'entre eux à la situation
financière des départements c'està-dire
la perte de péréquation la capacité
d'autofinancement net rapporté aux
recettes réell de fonctionnement la
capacité de désendettement et pour les
trois autres aux dépenses sociales qu'il
prennent en charge pourcentage de
bénéficiire d'aide par relative des
dépenses d'aide sociale dans budget du
département effet ciseau entre la
progression des dépenses sociales et la
progression des recettes réles de
fonctionnement à l'issue de ces travaux
menés donc par
l'IGA la mission a préconisé de rendre
éligible à la seconde section du fond
donc c'est 85 millions les départements
dont la situation est jugée comme
critique au regard d'au moins quatre
critères sur
6 concernant la Vienne votre département
tro critères parmi les six définis par
l'IGA relève une bonne situation 3/ si
concernant la corise et le Tarne puisque
ce sont deux départements que vous avez
cité cinq critères parmi les six
relèvent une situation critique tandis
que les six critères relèvent une
situation critique pour la Guyane autre
département que vous avez cité au total
ce sont donc 23 départements qui vont
bénéficier d'une aide exceptionnelle au
titre de la seconde section du fond ils
devront à cette fin conclure une
convention avec l'État indiquant les
engagements qu'ils prennent pour
faciliter le rétablissement de leur
situation financière la répartition de
la seconde section du fond est ainsi
concentrée sur les départements les plus
en difficulté déterminé en fonction
d'une analyse objective il n'y a là
aucun arbitraire je suis heureux de
pouvoir vous l'indiquer de la même
manière les aides versés à chacun des
départements éligibles ont été calculés
en fonction des six critères objectifs
précités je ne note que la corise tout
comme le Tarne percevront à ce titre des
sommes inférieures à cell que le
précédent gouvernement leur avait
attribué dans le cadre du fond d'urgence
de
2011 il est vrai en revanche que les
départements d'outrem n'avait rien perçu
à ce titre du fait de choix opéré par ce
même gouvernement ce qui nous semblait
injuste merci Monsieur Fouchet monsieur
le ministre un petit mot simplement
c'est pas parce que la corise euh
perçoit un peu moins qu'elle percevait
auparavant dans la liste elle est le
département qui perçoit le plus
offerreur de ma part donc je suis pas
d'accord du tout avec vous sur les
critères qui ont été utilisés sur le
rapport de l'IGA bon il y a des
départements qui ont fait beaucoup de
social mais qui ont su gérer leur social
nous c'est ce que nous avons fait donc
un peu c'est une prime est-ce que c'est
pas une prime à la mauvaise gestion
c'est la question que je peux me poser
mais en tout cas euh de nombreux
départements ne sont pas satisfaits de
cette répartition je veux le le dis je
pense que le ministre a dû l'entendre
bon il suffit peut-être euh peut-être
difficile de voir les choses mais la
prochaine fois de faire autrement merci
Monsieur le Ministre merci l'ordre du
jour appelle la